so in case you guys didn't know it I'm a  star yes indeed yesterday yeah a dozen  student journalists from Roberto  Clemente middle school in Gaithersburg  Maryland came to Fox to interview me  they're doing a documentary on prominent  Americans and they came with lights  cameras put me in the hot seat they  asked how do you prepare for the five  how do you write a newspaper column why  do you write so many books these are  really bright kids I had a great time so  you should be on a lookout for Sofia  Karol and Samantha Jennifer Caitlin Zoey  Melanie Nicole and Reva rising stars on  their way to the most selective high  schools and I'm so glad you filled in  for me on that yeah heartbroken when I  said no but